the movie home team available for
streaming this coming friday on netflix
it is about the year off
that sean payton had from the nfl
suspended from the league and he went
and he coached his kids youth football
team based on the true story and the man
who plays sean payton in the movie is
here on the rich eisen show the great
kevin james how you doing kevin good
buddy how are you i'm doing fine so uh
i'm just gonna go straight in and ask
the most awkward question to start
things off uh are you uh now
the leading candidate to replace sean
payton
with the new orleans saints oh
are you is that are you this would be
this would be a brilliant thing if i
pulled this off as a uh promotional item
as a jets fan right i
came in
i lured him in yes
yes and just kind of got him away with
this made him do this movie told him
he's gonna do this movie and stuff like
that they're changing things and trying
to get in there and planting these seeds
and just kind of told him he should
retire there's other options or just get
him away from the saints
and uh yeah i wish i could say i hadn't
done that but uh
man
came out of nowhere i was about to say
kevin uh you'd have to do that 30 more
times
to 30 other coaches like make 30 more
movies about their lives
you know
be around them uh you know burn them out
burn them out however you want and then
get them out you have to do that 30 more
times
well who says i'm not you know what i'm
working on other projects and it's going
to take some time
i might not see it but my kids will see
the jets win
it's a slow burn we call that a slow
burn uh that's right i know but how wild
is that huh that uh
[Music]
you know this is kind of crazy yeah i
mean out of nowhere to me i i honestly i
didn't know i i no idea um
you know it just i don't know i have no
i guess it will be revealed why or what
i i don't know well you just said he
just said it was kind of time to step
away and i think it's you know um you've
been around this business quite a bit
kevin uh maybe the greatest promotional
ploy to get everybody to see your movie
about you in the history of promotional
plays you know let me tell you something
i'll take it i will take it
but
unfortunately i think it had nothing to
do with i don't know i mean it's it's
maybe maybe it is maybe my movie was so
bad
do you think do you think
that's not the movie the movie is good
promise you the movie is great yes but
i'm saying maybe that's like because
think of that you hear the greatest news
that that's pretty good news you hear
somebody's making a movie about your
life and you're like wow how does it get
better from there and he says who's
playing me
is it matt damon or dicaprio and you go
hold on no no it's none of those guys
kevin james
and then you just kind of go okay i
gotta rethink my life
and i quit
oh yeah
no how about this though kevin here hold
on a second how about this
because this film home team again is
streaming available uh starting on
friday
netflix
uh about his one year away from the
saints
he's now created another year away from
the saints thus a sequel
already baked in
home team two
on netflix at some point
your thoughts how about that
i am so in this is crazy rich eisen i
did not put this together you did how
about that now you need to get a fee
somehow you need to be included somehow
um i do like it i like it yes i don't
know if the people of new orleans are
going to like it
but
well let's jump into this one um so um
obviously you're a jet fan and a
football fan so you you know you
remember when uh sean payton uh was told
by the league you got to sit out for a
year yep um so you know the story how
was this brought to you as an idea you
know you playing sean payton in this
movie how was that brought to you
handler brought it to me sandler brought
the idea to me
and i i didn't know about it i uh did
you know about that by the way i knew i
i mean obviously i knew about the
suspension and i remember you know right
the whole thing back in the day uh
but i didn't know there was a year where
he was suspended i didn't remember that
was the punishment and they didn't know
he went home
and reconnected with us and started
coaching his kids uh football team and
took him to the championship which was
it was you know an amazing time he's
like and he said is the greatest season
of coaching
in his career which i think
let's be honest the super bowl is he's
lying he's clearly lying but second
second the kid right second you get to
home to your kids in a second for sure
yes
but no which one yeah nothing beats the
super bowl i don't care who you know we
all know that
um so
i didn't know about that but that was
such an interesting story to me the
story was just uh
i i couldn't believe it was actually
true that he did that and
it just seemed like a perfectly
great
sports family movie to make i mean i was
like i couldn't believe it wasn't done
and uh i was i jumped in you jumped in
so sandler brings it to you
uh at what point were you brought or to
peyton or peyton to you to have
conversations about all of well that was
one of the things i said is sean in
because it feels weird to be doing a
story about his life
he's in he's in um and
you know he was he was great he was uh
uh christa tone who is uh who who is
actually it's a whole
convoluted it's a little story that uh
uh they're him and taylor lautner are
friends with
sean and and uh chris dates uh megan
who's sean's daughter and this and that
so they were all in in the workings of
this thing megan produced a piece called
cutting oranges which was like a small
documentary piece on uh sean coaching
this team and that's what we saw and
based it all on and uh and it was such a
great story uh that yeah he would sean
was in
and i went out there and he couldn't
have been better with me man he he took
me through everything
uh uh he took me to the saints facility
showed me every it was during the draft
too so he was
everything was going on i got to see how
he operates what he does and try to take
what i could and put some stuff in the
movie and you know it's also like a bad
news bears type movie it really didn't
have much to do with the scenes it had
nothing to do with the suspension really
it has to do with all
what took place after and it was uh
you know that's what you know excited me
that's so cool man so i do remember
kevin i do remember that uh documentary
right i do remember that that his
daughter put together right so that was
the
the uh the the basis and the genesis of
something yes to put it together and and
then so the draft so you you saw i mean
look i mean
the man steps away from a coaching gig
after all that time so you saw the grind
i mean
you saw like
that's a serious time of year but you
also saw i'm sure how cool and chill he
is which is kind of crazy for in the
middle of the grind i mean you probably
saw everybody was coming up to him and
everybody you know you see it and uh he
makes decisions you know like you just
see what a pro he is he knows what he's
doing
uh so uh you know i i was just asking
them questions about my jets and that
was about it
how are we gonna
fare and uh you know
he was he was very kind with that and
you guys will be okay he was wrong we
weren't okay this season you know but uh
you know
he he he was amazing and he was he was
he's funny he's a great guy a great
leader and you get to see how he
operates and that's really what i took
tried to get his accent down his accent
is all over the joint so mine is kind of
oh he's got like a little bit of a
southern yeah draw like sometimes but
he's from california and then he's from
he's it's tough he's he he admitted
stuff and he was on set watching me and
i was like i can't do this no
really and he's like really like don't
worry yeah he's
he's it's tough try to lock him down i
couldn't get him down because he'll
he'll bounce in and out
i know i mean and because well i mean i
guess if you're living in the bayou for
16 years right you kind of you kind of
adopt it in a way um yeah and did
schneider scream you can do it to him at
any point in time i mean
he did and i don't think it made it into
the movie it just felt like it was not a
part of this movie but
he did
i think he's got to do that everywhere
i think it is yes it is it is it is what
america really wants kevin you know from
rob schneider uh i got kevin james here
home team available he's amazing in it
though he was great in this movie too
he's fantastic well i mean this is this
is great i mean some of the sandler gang
had put back together for a movie with
uh
with well his wife is in it too right uh
jackie
you know ex-wife uh and schneider's
current uh
wife but uh
yeah okay
and adam was
this is all cool right i mean obviously
i was ex-wife so i didn't it was more on
schneider because schneider had to kiss
her i guess so i was like all right
that's up to you man i i like working
oh my god it's available for again
streaming uh this coming friday on
netflix um home team kevin james here on
the rich eisen show so okay this is
great man and so did uh peyton probably
loved
everything you've done he must have
known everything that you did because
he's locked in on watching things and
movies and tv and you must have been
very well versed on everything you did
he loved we we had a fun time he's he's
a great man i really i hope he i wish it
was an honor to play him and i wish him
the best well i'm telling you kevin uh
if there is a movie about his second
year off from the nfl you want to get in
on that because i think he's about to
live with the vita loca over the next
year
i think he is about to he is about to go
do that all right man well thanks for
the time um congrats on this i can't
wait to see it um i i know the i know
the story and i know that there's a nice
fun
uh story to tell but also you know nice
and cool in the way that it all works
out and how you know orient family
oriented it is so i can't wait to see it
i can't wait to see thanks rich anytime
kevin you'd be well appreciate it bud
right back at you that's kevin james at
kevin james on twitter kevin james
official on instagram right here on the
rich eisen show